Namotasa bhagavato arahato sambodasa Namotasa bhagavato arahato sambodasa Namotasa bhagavato arahato sambodasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So I thought this evening I'd tackle this neoliberalism, save us all, and the role of Buddhism, of Buddhadharma in that particular ideology.
So just to remind ourselves an ideology is just, you know,
a set of beliefs and principles that go on to a policy but as an ideology as an idealism as well there's always some future goal some sort of shangri-la that it's always heading towards and um it always has even in uh even in uh marxist terms that the seed of destruction
is always in capitalism.
But that's true as we've discovered from the last century of any ideology, communism, national socialism, even democracy, but democracy at least has this sort of self-correction every so often.
And as we've discovered, it only really works when the society tends to be fairly peaceful with itself.
As we see these days, there's a leaning towards the right again, towards authoritarianism.
So the Buddha himself didn't fashion Buddhism.
He simply taught a practical path to liberate us and the understanding that underlines it.
So it's really about ethics.
And he belonged to a period before writing.
So therefore, there isn't this philosophy and systems theory and all that.
It just didn't exist at that time.
The thought was really very practical.
Now, the fundamental attitude that actually drives neoliberalism is greed, acquisitiveness.
um i'm just quoting here from oliver stone's movie which was in 87 1987 called wall street some of you might have seen it gordon gecko is the sort of anti-hero played by michael douglas and he gives this speech and he says the point is ladies and gentlemen that greed for lack of a better word is good greed is right greed works greed clarifies cuts through and captures the essence of the evolutionary spirit
greed in all its forms greed for life greed for money for love knowledge has marked the upward surge of mankind my doesn't sound so what it does is it makes you a very special human being you know you're out for yourself uh this sort of very selfish attitude that i should have what i want when i want it if you remember frank sinatra's old song you know i did it my way
And of course, it's a corruption of what Darwin said.
Darwin, I quote him here, it is not the strongest of the species that survive, not the most intelligent, but the ones most responsive to change.
So this word fittest actually means adaptable.
But, you know, ever since the beginning of the Industrial Revolution, we've had this idea that, you know, there'll come a time when we can produce enough stuff so that everybody has everything.
so uh there's a couple of books here that i can mention towards the end i might come back to that but i i would i just mentioned this uh book by jill westcott called the psychological roots of the climate crisis and it's it's it's um it's about it it sort of brings together many things but one thing that she points out is that the wealthy nurtured the concept of neoliberalism through right-wing think tanks and they captured the republicans
and eventually the Tories.
So that's dear old Margaret Thatcher for us.
So now this acquisitiveness, this greed, it operates in a market, right?
So we're all now entrepreneurs in this market and we all want everything all at once.
And what it does, of course, is it creates this competition.
But of course, it's a competition that is antagonistic because either you're, at best, my rival, at worst, you're my direct enemy.
So I'm always working against somebody.
Now, you can't say that competition is bad, is all bad, because it does actually create efficiency and inventiveness.
In fact, in the worst cases where you have this aggressive competition, war, in the Second World War, remember,
jet planes jet engines radar and the computer were developed so yeah there's a tremendous irony there but the thing is that what neoliberalism presumes is that society is at best when it services the market we're all individuals we're all working against each other in order to get the biggest piece of the pie we can and the whole process is very antagonistic
But when you look at something like academia, where scientists from all over the world might be working on a particular project,
They're very happy to share with each other their discoveries.
Now, they're not motivated by power or money.
I mean, they're given a salary.
I mean, they might covet the Nobel Prize, but it's usually just sheer interest in the scientific investigation.
So here we have a collaborative competitiveness, which is a very different atmosphere altogether.
I think it's something the Buddha would have liked.
Now, the downside of this, of course, is that if you're not a player in the market, then in a sense, you've only yourselves to blame.
And in blaming the victims, if you remember going back to that period, those from the rest of Europe won't remember this, but we had this fellow called Tebbit who told people to get onto their bikes, you know, like, it's up to you, you've got to get the work.
And if you don't get the work, well, that's your problem, you're to blame.
So workers begin to lose their rights because basically you have to negotiate with your employer.
um and uh and that and that and the competition between workers determines the cost which will go down and down so this is the gig economy isn't it this is what we mean by the race to the bottom so i give a definition here of a race to the bottom a competitive situation where a company a state or a nation attempts to undercut
the competition's prices by sacrificing quality standards or worker safety or reducing labor costs.
And you can see, for instance, when Uber started in London, I'm hoping that the situation is the same in the rest of the world, or I'm not sure.
Basically, those who wanted to join Uber were in competition with each other.
So you can imagine,
a a parent who has who has children holidays and all that sort of stuff a young woman who has a mortgage etc and a young fella who's got no problems whatsoever he's only about 21 or something
and they are bidding for your ride well if if if the man with all the if the parent with all the problems is charging you 30 and the woman charges you 25 and he charges you 20 then if if if the parent wants that right they've got to come all the way down to 20. and that's what happens everything starts moving downwards
The worst example, of course, is this recent sacking of 800 workers by the P&O ferry line.
Interestingly enough, they were losing 100 million, but at the same time, they paid out 270 million to their dividend, to their shareholders.
So you can see it's not very fair, is it?
And we all know about this tremendous
earth well it comes out to be a lie doesn't it this this thing about trickle down you know eventually the wealth sort of trickles down and and everybody's happy but it doesn't trickle down to the unemployed to the disabled or the old the aged
and uh these players of course are not in the market so now that would be a real drag draining money from the market so the only way to get around that is of course to privatize all the social services so that these companies get their 10 percent i don't know what's happening in the rest of europe but now there are many gp surgeries that are being taken over by a company called centene and even the daily mail said it was the most
avaricious of insurance companies so it's all bad news isn't it but the big thing is of course is that this competition uh just undermines a sense of common wealth you know like you you it's no longer a caring society you're not actually caring for each other you're just trying to find your way make money
So that means that any government or charitable effort that tries to do something about your basic physical or material well-being, people in need would undermine the entrepreneurial spirit of competition.
See, people have got to get out there and get into it.
And of course, neoliberalism hates governments interfering with the markets.
So there was this whole business about very few regulations.
Well, we knew what happened.
The banks went berserk.
And then who had to step in to save them?
Us, the poor ordinary punter.
So you can see that this is diametrically opposed to anything that the Buddha would teach.
the wonderful thing is that of course people are highly stressed in that sort of system all the way down from cso's all the way down to the ordinary worker now it seems that the uh world economic forum at davos you know where they where the um the mighty where the rich and the powerful the high and mighty meets to decide how to rule the world they were overjoyed to hear about mindfulness
So mindfulness would help people with their stress.
So you began to tell all the workers that were stressed out, you've got to take a course in mindfulness and stress reduction.
And if you happen to be even more stressed by it, even more stressed, well, all you had to do was find a place in the office or somewhere and just sit there for a while and watch your breath and it would all disappear.
as though stress were entirely a person's internal response to a situation.
But as we know, the stress that's put upon you from the outside has a great deal to do with our own mental states.
So this wonderful gift that the Buddha gave us of investigating our lives and our being in order to achieve complete liberation from suffering is now being used to support a system which is doing exactly the opposite.
What an irony!
And of course, what the neoliberal system is doing is the work of Mara.
Now Mara is the evil one.
If you remember, just before the Buddha's liberation, Mara came and said,
come on and gave him this great doubt so come on what are you doing why why are you doing this why are you going through all this pain this suffering why don't you get back to your family and get back to sensual pleasures and how it was in the old days before you took up this silly this silly idea and of course the buddha touches the earth now this is the important thing he touches the earth and the the goddess of the earth arises
and says tomorrow no the buddha has every right to do this because he has perfected the virtue of generosity okay so in other words the buddha's uh should we say commitment came from his desire also to um free everybody from suffering um and this is really
something that undermines the neoliberal agenda.
The idea that we can actually be like citizens who are helping each other.
So if you remember during the lockdown here, suddenly neighbors realized they could help themselves.
It was unknown.
You could actually knock on a neighbor's door and say, how are you doing?
And be there to help them out.
This was a new discovery, it seems.
So now, just before I carry on with generosity, the question is, what can we personally do?
Well, the obvious thing, of course, is to be aware of what we're buying, not to support these satanic factories in Bangladesh and Cambodia and even in China.
But coming back now to generosity, I'm sure you've noticed that when you do something out of a sense of care for yourself, like you might buy a warm jumper or something like that, there's always a feeling good about that.
You feel good about yourself.
You're caring for yourself.
Have you noticed that when you care for somebody else, when you look after somebody else, when you buy something for somebody, when you give something for somebody or spend time for somebody else, the joy that comes from it is much more long lasting.
And it's that shift towards going away from this me towards we is where we can begin to find a different sort of economic system.
Of course, that sounds a bit glib, you know, me to we and all that.
But basically, it's that sense of, you know, to bring back that sense of community.
And I would just like to end this lovely quote that I've got from
from the Buddha, if beings knew, as I knew, the results of giving and sharing, they would not eat without having given, nor would the stain of miserliness overcome their minds.
Even if it were their last bite, their last mouthful, they would not eat without having shared, if there were someone to receive the gift.
But because beings do not know this, as I know, the results of giving and sharing, they eat without having given, and the stain of miserliness overcomes their mind.
So it's possible that we can have a life of joyfulness, which is a shared joy with people around us.
and and to get away from this very tight sense of this little self like like a little castle which has to defend itself against everybody um and that and and you see it in these in uh the new woke you know especially xr rebellion which is trying to wake people up to recognizing that things you know where things are getting worse we have to do something about it
And you'll find great resistance from that, from those people who, of course, are committed to neoliberalism.
So all we can hope for is a change of attitude.
You'll get politicians saying, oh, well, what we need is better jobs and better housing.
But that's all within the system of neoliberalism.
so in a sense if we're going to move towards something which is much more just much more equitable much more kind much more caring it's that fundamental attitude that has to change and let's let's hope that when it does happen because the seeds of destruction are within capitalism itself when it does happen hopefully uh
in the near future let's just hope it's not another ideology because that again will create problems and what the Buddha is saying is if you ground yourself in the right attitude
and you recognize that times that that the situation of times are in a constant flux then you can always come at a particular situation not from some preset view and opinion but from this attitude of compassion of sympathetic joy of caring of love and say
Anyway, I hope my words have been of some assistance, that they have not caused even greater confusion, and that by your commitment to the good life of compassion and joy, you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.